i don't like end of the world stuff it
freaks me out he loves that stuff
it's my favorite genre it's my favorite
genre aren't you
do you think it's going to happen do you
think we're going to like face something
like that
well i'm going to tell you the two
things that could happen my friend and
the two things that could happen
i don't know if i can handle these like
i'm very delicate with this stuff
do you really have things that are gonna
yeah i'm leaning forward like this
no these are no it's not is there like a
meteor there's two things none of media
or none
super volcano no these are two things
that could actually happen
okay okay um the number one thing is
peak oil
you've heard of people have heard of
peak oil yes fog of war
tell me [ __ ] no you know what was the
fog war the movie was called collapse
collapse yes and basically it's the um
theory that you know oil isn't something
that
the earth just constantly makes it's did
we just have
enough we have it you know fossil fuel
we have it once we use it
it's gone it's not something that the
earth generates
right and peak oil is the point of
production where we're at the tip
and then we can't you know
we can't grab enough for
well i don't know how to say it there's
not enough running around to go around
we're at a point where yeah is that one
of them yeah yeah we run out what's so
funny because i can't explain it [ __ ]
because i'm not a scientist
is that why are you laughing no all
right you just said him wanting to
having sex or making love that would
want to make you murder yourself
he gets a little bit yeah but if they
also need to just say this all right
what do they say about this room that's
what it is
okay what it is when out there out there
i'm gonna fold this laundry and do all
kinds of stuff
i'm gonna do i would lose taxes out
there and everybody love each other we
love each other but um
that's the one thing what is it it's
documentary collapse
but it scared the [ __ ] out of it oh it's
a documentary it's a documentary
okay yeah this is gonna scare the [ __ ]
on me okay so what happens but worth
watching
worth watching and the second thing that
can happen is also um the singularity
where machines what happens if we run
out oil what's go
like what's the chaotic well the problem
is is that um
all our food comes from different
countries we get blueberries from
you know brazil we get you know
strawberries so and all these things are
delivered through
modes of transportation that have to do
with fossil fuels right oil
right when we run out of oil the whole
system will break down got it right we
no one will be able to drive we're not
going to be able to receive certain
things
and and we'll just break down as a
society it'll be chaos
because everything's riding on oil right
everything
because it's everything so the only
things that will work are calculators
yeah but we if we don't i know
i know 83
that is true nikki yeah okay
and we're not creating an alternative
alternative power source right
so it's like eventually one day
we're just gonna run out and we don't
have anything to like
as a substitute i think we're going to
break down and society's going to break
down
the second thing is singularity if when
machine gets consciousness oh it's going
to happen
right and then yeah and then you know
we'll have a war with
machines and it'll be like a terminator
i like that ending better
more dramatic that one more german i
feel like it's going to bring us
together
well the thing i hear about that that
that one is that it's going to happen
so fast it'll just be like all of a
sudden
just now it'll happen and then we're
done there's
not going to be a war because it will be
over as soon as it starts
what is that um documentary where the
guy who created the
yeah that one where he says the
trajectory has been slow so far
but once it goes up this way it goes the
the trajectory goes straight up
yeah yeah yeah so we're all going to be
like perfect
when you're saying that it's going to
happen just like that can we [ __ ] the
robots first for a little bit
before they take over well they let us
have sex with them
a little bit i want to have some robot
sex yeah yeah i wonder what um
robot vagina is like not as fun as robot
dick
i mean why wait why'd you say that like
that i mean
to be with your eyes all googly eyes and
your mouth like that that's funny think
about it like
to be able to construct the inner
cavernous region of a woman using
[ __ ]
metal or not metal but using like a
flashlight static stuff
is not as easy as having just
a rod really a roblox a robot all about
robot dick the robot
i already watched that kind of porn
where they're like basically machine
gun things you're telling me robots
can't get pringles
can't get a pringle can and like
dishwashing
like his self-made yeah talk
no what a robot i made a i made a my
brother and i made a um homemade
homemade vagina
flashlight yeah
a plastic glove right brilliant to um a
sponge sponges
and some rubber bands right and we we
took the pringles out yeah
we did we constructed it right my
brother made my brother made one
three days ago oh he still does
overnight because he has some stuff left
over from last time
our parents house yeah because i found
one pringles pancan
i go well what are mine did it work
and he goes i throw only one we have two
well then you use it
okay good but did it work yeah it works
was it great
it's great so why can't a robot just go
there get it and stick it inside
one that you like buy like that's
actually right yeah and they're good
a bunch of them here run out and they're
good
well here's the problem with it here's
the problem
they're not warm oh they can be warm
no yeah you use um farming there's oils
the warming oils warming oils you can
make it warm
okay here's another thing cause that's a
problem i have with dildos they're not
warm
yeah they're always just so sterile and
cold
well it's also you maybe you can invent
something shark tank
yeah we can sell it i've been driving my
curling iron
you have a brief window
and then it's very painful